[Music]
we have done a Relentless pursuit of
investigative facts on this case and
unfortunately we are running out of
investigative leads I have concerns that
this investigation will go cold without
the community's assistance
breaking news at 4 a plea to the public
Metro Police holding a press conference
this afternoon on the murder of a
homeless couple who were shot to death
in a makeshift shelter the victims
shella Huey and Vincent Esposito were
found dead back on February 20th behind
an AutoZone on Nellis Boulevard near di
Huey's sister also spoke asking those
responsible to come forward anyone with
any information is asked to contact
police or Crime Stoppers at 702-385-55
remember you can remain anonymous and
submit those tips online